Film Courage: How did you get your first job
as a director/filmmaker?
Dale Stelly, Filmmaker: How did I get my first
job?
My first music video that I shot on Super
16 millimeter was for an up-and-coming local
hip-hop artist named Power Man and to make
long story short I met him at Roscoe’s Chicken
and Waffles and me working on a lot of music
videos I was ready to start directing.
This was like 1996?
No, I didn’t start my company then.
I started directing and I didn’t start my
company until 1998.
But from ’96 to ’98 I started getting
the confidence to start my company and everything.
The first video that I directed on film was
for an artist named Power Man and it was a
12,000 budget which at that time for me was
a decent budget and I shot a great video with
some great post-production hookups that I
had when I was working at Cinesite so I was
able to incorporate some green screen and
take my directing debut to the best level
that I can with the resources and the people
that I knew that kind of helped me pull that
video off and I was on my way from that video.
I started directing one music video after
the next.
Being able to shoot on film and it looked
professional.
At that time it was very hard to get your
hands on film unless you had a real budget.
You had to rent the film camera and you need
someone who needs to know how shoot film and
change the film mags and a whole different
filmmaking process so I really feel good about
my journey because I came from actually filmmaking
background originating my first films on 35
mm is way different from shooting on digital
cameras now.
If you’re shooting on film you’ve got
to get the film developed and then you’ve
got to go through telecine and it takes way
more skill to me to shoot something on 35
millimeter in and then to raise up an HD camera
and press the auto settings you know what
I mean?
And think that you’re making a movie or
whatever.
Which is pretty much what’s going on today.
These digital cameras are making everything
as easy as possible to acquire image and it
just kind of takes to me the filmmaking fun
out it when you don’t need a light meter
any more.
Back in the day shooting film you would measure
the light, measure the distance from the lens
to the actor.
It’s just different.
Still at the end of the day all people care
about is the end product but as a filmmaker
I’m just glad that I came from actual filmmaking
days in transition into the digital world
which makes me feel like an asset to a lot
of different productions when I come to the
table, to be intelligent across the whole
board when it comes to making a movie on film
or movie on digital.
Because some directors still…like Tarantino
I think he’s still shooting 35 millimeter.
People still have a love and respect for film
but it’s still a dying situation that some
of us are trying to keep alive.
Film Courage: Do you remember your call time
on that music video?
What was that morning like?
Dale: 8:00 a.m. and I remember shooting most
of the video in my neighborhood because I’ve
lived in my neighborhood for ever and ever
and everyone knew me and all the different
small businesses and my parents had a nice
house on the corner and I knew a bunch of
people with cars and stuff.
So I pulled off a cool little hip-hop video
in the neighborhood that came out nice for
a rap artist.
And I think we shot like 12 hours (8:00 am
to 8:00 pm) or something like that which was
standard filmmaking hours (12 hour days) and
it was exciting to shoot my first video on
film, on an ARRI SR3 camera, 24 frames per
second, all that good stuff when you are on
set you’re like “Wow?
I’m shooting my first actual film.”
It was dope.